[Music]
six over 24 for Butler gets a great
screen from Pam
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll start for Miami two threes for
Robinson Alex Len just came on for
Damian Jones bats a tap cam reddish and
say to them
[Applause]
you gotta love this Miami Heat team from
Duncan Robinson on the shot clock here's
Duncan
for triples to start the game for Duncan
rapist he gave up 65 points two games
ago before shaft to the Wizards
[Applause]
okay and then the ball moment Darren
Jones making one extra point with the is
57 game all-time against my that's good
I would tie it with Paul Pierce for the
second most games
next again thank you Steve
[Applause]
[Music]
from FIBA skater Jones jr. have DeAndre
hunter with 9 on the shot clock for
Miami and 321 left of again rapid
expansion the under a hunter tonight a
season and career high 28 points here
comes Butler through the d back to
Robinson shoots
still alive
char's
and Robinson from iron Kinney Duncan
Robinson in trays 12 Travis 31 points to
be used walk here to society
[Applause]
so good he is
the franchise record